wir haben Noel Gentil nenn ich bin Kurt
Müller und es scheint sie ein ziemlich
starken glauben an Gott zu haben und
dann wäre meine Frage glaubst du auch
an die Bibel ist sicher nie wieder
waren es in den ersten zwölf nicht dort
spielen macht
ich glaube an Gott
um dort ist für mich aber ein Konzept
her ich glaub nicht unbedingt eine Bibel
ich glaube dass die Bibel
um auch Wahrheiten hat aber dass die
Bibel auch ganz schön gefährlich ist
mein Gott dessen Konzept das heißt ich
glaube an den Deal an den Gott
Menz Mai Prozent der Wille zum berechnen
um das gute in uns
das also wie alles zusammenhängt das
ist das woran ich glaube
und dann ein eine andere Frage
oder glaubst du auch einen Engel hatte
sich für eine eng ist die Gegner so das
Leben manche Leute sagen für den Unfall
und so
auch hier nicht verletzt ich muss einen
Schutzengel gehabt haben musst du
vielleicht auch schon auf einigen
Gegenwind
mit dem nächsten Gegner nicht andauernd
um meine Kinder sind enge wir werden
keine Fällen sind wir irgendwie
pm wer das Musikmachen ist für mich
irgendwie wir müssen auch um die
wahrscheinlich in einem Spiel hat seinen
Sinn gesehen
aber mich kann sie noch nicht
und um das ist wahrscheinlich das was
ich meine mit
mit dem guten mit der Kraft die alles
zusammen
hält das göttliche ernster Miene
werden Engel